kate mcarthur thanks very much indeed
for joining us here today first of all
why do you think that this letter is
necessary what has the impact of climate
change been on farmers in kenya where
you are for example
yeah thank you for having me on the show
the letter is so important because and
he's just reminding the world leaders of
the promises they made in terms of
reducing emissions on climate finance
and ensuring that the business climate
is um governed by environmental friendly
um
policies
so that those are just really reminding
them to deliver on their promise because
then the producers here in africa are
doing their best to mitigate and adopt
the climate changes what fairtrade
farmers are currently doing they're
planting trees in their cocoa and coffee
plantation to ensure that the crops are
shaded and that the yields can somewhat
um
remain as they were before and also
protecting the soils they've adapted to
using solar solutions for their lighting
for their cooking and also even uh
adaptive technology in terms of
fairly delivering standards and training
materials to them so they're doing the
best within the abilities that they have
but we're saying is they need more we
need more as producers uh the hundred
billion annual promise will go a long
way in strengthening some of the
strategies that the producers already
implementing
well yes and we've heard in recent weeks
that president biden is pledging to
double the us's climate finance to 11.4
billion dollars does that give you
encouragement that world leaders are
stepping up
it's really a mixed feeling because the
previous promises only about less than
two percent actually got to the small
boulder producers so we can always
always have hope but we need to have a
great mechanism to ensure that that
the pledges are delivered and delivered
to the smallholder farmers so i'm glad
that the issue is coming up i'm glad
that they're promising more but they
actually need to act and ensure that
that money comes to the producer so that
they can um uh address the climate
changes after all most of the
smallholder from producers are the least
emitters and there's too much burden on
them so it's good to get the the world
leaders to commit and deliver onto their
promise
you're also calling on world leaders to
strengthen business regulations but
realistically how far can governments go
to force private businesses to make
decisions based on awareness of climate
change
it's interesting and it's doable because
at fair trade we do have some businesses
that really have a sustainable supply
chain solutions and strategies within
their corporate uh solutions and that
includes the environment and when they
do business with the fair trade farmers
it's in the long haul so with a long
haul with a long-term partnership the
producers then are able to invest in
environmental friendly
solutions and how the government then
can come in is to ensure as they're
giving
developing policies and giving business
permits there are all this environmental
due diligence incorporated in all these
rules i believe the government is a very
big instrument and i think they they
support
implementation of sustainable supply
chains for businesses and providing
guidance and as well as um enabling
environment it could be through
incentives or tax breaks or whatever it
is then the business um will be
encouraged to to adopt environmental
friendly strategies within the supply
chain
policies ultimately businesses are
trying to make profits aren't they and
margins can be pretty tight especially
in this country for example with energy
prices going up do consumers have to
accept they may have to pay higher
prices for climate aware products
currently we find some of our producers
some of our consumers sorry they're
already paying that price and that is
what is helping the fair uh
from farmers and smallholder workers
really thrive
but again what we are saying is it
doesn't have to be at an extreme premium
we're seeing as the
sustainable production sustainable
consumption
wave catches on there could be
additional costs that everyone within
the supply chain will cover but the more
we do it from the consumers from the
business partners from the governments
then over time with economies of scale
then you find that the the premium
doesn't have to be that high for the
consumers to pay
and what we are we are noticing now is
that consumers who are who are buying
sustainably produced products could be
fairtrade it could be any other it going
a long way in ensuring that the farmers
are getting a fair wage
that goes to
meet their basic needs like food
education
really basic needs that
any any consumer any producer needs to
be met so it's i would want to imagine
it's a continuum it's a face the more we
adopt sustainable production and
consumption the the more efficient in
terms of production and economies of
scale will achieve
and make things more
affordable across the world
kate mcarthur thanks very much indeed